i hated ping pong actually like growing
up in school
like in high school we had a pink there
was like a ping pong club
in in the lunch room so i remember i was
playing basketball football i played
tennis played volleyball
wrestling and i remember i would come
through the lunchroom and see these kids
playing
ping-pong and i used to make fun of them
and i'm like oh man [ __ ] nerds
so crazy look at these kids with short
shorts and a stick
i was like oh my god what is this right
so
so i i hated this sport right uh and um
so so during the off season of my sports
i started shooting pool
i got into pool like i like pool a lot
and i i went to a billiards hall
and i built a billiard store and i had
bought a pool stick right
for a little bit of money and then i
went back a week later
and then stole another one so i switched
i switched the pull stick out for
another pull stick
right and so now i had this really nice
full stick which gave me the uh uh the
idea that i was good at pool
and i really wasn't i was okay i was
okay uh and i got hustled for some money
at a pool
hall money that i really didn't have but
you know i was always mad at my wife i
lost the bet
pay up so i lost the bet and uh i got a
little pissed off
and i took the pool stick and i hit it
on the um pool table
and it it cracked like the poster just
cracked so i was even more angry
and then i turn around i look and i see
some asian kids
playing ping pong right to the pool i
had ping pong table
right so i look over there and i don't
know i think i think i was more being
bullied
i was probably being a bully because i
don't think i really wanted to play ping
pong yeah i went over there and i was
like hey
i want to get a hit i didn't even ask i
was like i want to get a hit
and the guy was like you play i'll say
no i don't play this
and he gave me the paddle and then uh
out of anger i
had played tennis also so so i knew how
to hold it somewhat
right out of anger it was more me just
trying to lash out at the ball because i
broke my pool stick
and the ball went on the table the guy
goes oh man wow you play
and i was like nah i don't play this he
was like yo you should go check out this
club
there's there's a club downtown i mean
in midtown manhattan you should go check
it out
it's it's a ping-pong club and i was
like
there's a ping-pong club what do you
mean there's a place where people
go and play this like i couldn't believe
it he was like yeah it is
so i was like really so i wanted to go
check it out cause i just wanted to see
i couldn't believe that there was
a place where pro ping pong players
played
so so and you know i was an athlete
right so i played every sport
so i was like there's pros that play
this no way is it possible
so i go down i go check it out and i go
i go inside this pool hall right and
huge pool hall and then it's like
i think it's like six tables and people
were playing like bom
bom bom bom bom and i was like whoa this
is crazy
i was like whoa this is this is this is
nuts this is some next level stuff
so uh i tried to get i tried i wanted to
play right away right because i'm a
seasoned athlete i want to play
right nobody would play with me they
would they were like oh
my uh i'm tired oh i got to go somewhere
and they would play with someone else
and then i would get so tight and and
all i kept thinking in my mind was like
these [ __ ] don't know me man i
would shoot up this whole place
i was so tight i was like yo what the
so so i would just keep going so i'm the
kind of person i like to go
where people don't want me if you don't
want me there i will be there
right in your face so you got to that uh
you got to get a table tennis club
so i went to the club and no one wanted
to [ __ ] with you no one wanted to play a
game with you
no one no one everyone was like being an
ass so um
this this this dude came in uh and i
think maybe it was his first time at the
club and he saw me saying that he came
to me goes hey
uh do you have a partner and i was like
nah
not not really and he goes if you play
with me
like two or three times a week i can pay
twenty dollars
and i was like what twenty dollars so
for me that was a hustle or twenty
dollars wait a minute
you know just to play ping pong because
i could hit you know i'm an athlete
i can play any sport it doesn't matter
so i was like all right so
i would play with this guy um you know
maybe two times a week three times a
week and
he paid me 20 dollars right and then uh
we'd talk a little bit you know
he would ask me about my family and i
was and i was like you know tell them
about my gang and stuff like that
and you know we we became chill right
and then uh but for him um
it was more like tv right because like
if you don't know anyone who's ever
lived that kind of life
or or been in those kind of situations
then it's tv it's a tv show
right i mean most people
um have never been around
guns or gangs or or been shot at
or or you know that kind of thing so but
they've seen it on tv
or in the movie right so when i was
telling him stuff
uh he was more more or less
um thinking this was like tv so he
wasn't taking me to work
weren't you worried that he might be a
cop nah because i
because we we can tell cops immediately
what kind of [ __ ] were you doing for
money like what were you doing for work
how
how what were you doing i didn't have
money i was broke man so that's yeah
you didn't you didn't have to make money
like in the gang you guys didn't do
anything
i never i never got into the like the
drug thing
and the cell and stuff never no never
really
i never i never even i never even did
drugs back then
they let you be in the gang without
doing any of that stuff because
i fight
if you just [ __ ] people up and they want
to keep you around if people had beef
like i was i wasn't afraid to bust off
like you know let's do it so but i never
i never got into that side right and
with the drug
stuff like i never for some reason i
just never i mean i didn't even drink
alcohol
until like what about like jacking cars
or anything oh yeah
everybody i got caught once for that so
what happened after you uh started
hanging out with this dude in the pool
honestly he's paying you 20 bucks every
time you play with him
so so the 20 bucks was was a hustle for
me so you know
it was good it was how i could eat
i got 20 now you know every day every
week what was it like it was like maybe
two or three times a week so i was
getting like 60 bucks a week man to play
[ __ ] ping pong you know
so so you know i mean what i did do a
lot when i was young i did a lot of
stealing
like a lot of [ __ ] stealing a lot
like for people's houses or
from where yo where'd you steal from i
never broke into people's houses
but we would jack people up on the train
like
people here like we're going to train
maybe like
five or six of us deep on the train and
there'll be someone sitting now
and you know if five people come around
people can't see really what's going on
until it's too late
so that i did a lot i did and then
just stealing [ __ ] from the stores and
stuff like that trying to see
how how how much what's the most
expensive thing we could get out of the
store
yeah like that but yeah but anyway uh
like when you would you get [ __ ] just to
keep it or would you sell it
to me sell it sell it keep it
but mostly sell it you know to make some
money and stuff like that
um but yeah so this this guy you know he
he he's paying me this twenty dollars
and uh like i said before
he really didn't understand how serious
what i was into for him it was like i
got the feeling for him it was like tv
and he
just kind of like yeah yeah whatever so
um you're entertaining him
one day i went to the club to go meet
him and uh
i had a 22 in my bag and um
it kind of like fell out of the bag and
uh
right in front of him which really
sucked and then
he looked at he looked at it then he
looked at me
and the look on his face was just weird
man it was it was weird
it was just like i think
everything that i had been talking about
i just came hit him right there
and then he was like and then before he
said anything i picked it up i was like
i gotta go
because at that point then i was a
little worried because you know
you don't know maybe he freak out and
call the police
you don't know and i don't want to stay
around i never stay around to find out
what goes on so
i picked it up and said yo i'm out and i
just left and the first thing i thought
about was like yo
there goes my twenty dollars i was like
yo twenty dollar hustle is done
for sure then the guy yep that's it but
i was gonna say you were talking to him
about doing all this stuff i mean he he
knew that you were
you know gun violence was in your life
he didn't you didn't stop to think like
you know maybe this guy
understands this you know most times
most times
if people has never been in a situation
how can someone understand that a 13
year old kid could have guns
right yeah if if you've never been in a
situation you've never been around
kids that have that mentality
then there's no way that you can
understand it
right but if you look at history in some
countries
kids are like 12 right
10 9 right and they're
been stolen and put in wars
at 9 10 11 12 13.
right with big with i never had no big
guns
like these kids walking around with big
guns right yeah so like
automatic rifles yeah so so it's like if
if if you don't know anyone
in that lifestyle then it's very hard to
comprehend
you know for him he was probably saying
uh maybe he's having some problems but
it's not that soon so
after you dropped your gun in front of
this guy and you took off
what happened like you obviously stayed
i mean you obviously yeah so i
played ping pong i no actually my ping
pong was going to end
then oh yeah you had no plan to do it no
zero because you didn't really care for
it no and plus i was not going to go
back there
go back there you're crazy i don't know
who else saw that so um
after um two days later the guy calls me
says hey are we still playing and i was
like what
so then i was a little worried in the
beginning
but then it was twenty dollars the money
overrules the worry mm-hmm
so and and you see that all the time
with a lot of like drug dealers
you know stop right there but now you
know what
i'm gonna go get that one more because i
need that money and then boom you get
caught yeah so so so
i was like you know 20 you know what 20
bucks worth the risk swift the risk
let's go
so so i went and i played the guy and
and the thing that was very interesting
he never gave me a let you know i never
got a lecture from this dude he never he
never said like yo what are you doing
you're going to ruin your life you
shouldn't do that because then i would
have just freaking just bounced and i
was like yeah i'm going to hit you
but he never ever said anything like
almost like
it is weird it was almost like it didn't
happen he never talked about it he never
mentioned anything he never said and you
were you were afraid that he was gonna
bring it up
i was always afraid he's gonna bring it
up right i was waiting for him to bring
it up
right i was waiting but it never came he
never he never said he just
played with me and then he says hey i
want to invite you to my house
what and and so he oh yeah exactly